you always are coming up with new stuff
and I'm told you have a new impression
well there's a guy love doing cuz I love
all his movies liam neeson yeah and I
just love this
let me tell you something Conan's
audience I have skills I've acquired
over 30 years skills that make me a
nightmare for audience like you if
you're laughs no harm will come to come
he's he's so animated I mean every movie
is just like I don't have much time
that's a car we'll call what would it be
like it Gelson's this is the 10 items
[Applause]
he's always in that space he's always
there you know every movie starts with a
phone call a phonetic Hiroko no harm or
come pay off nothing so I just hope
there's that gap wouldn't get a laugh
you know you're taking you took a bit
out of retirement a bit that you retired
a long time ago right and yes sort of
put it in the trunk maybe you'll never
see it again
yeah basically you thought it could come
back time to change you could well yeah
I did Scarface at Thanksgiving dinner
years ago years ago and it would work
but it didn't kill so then recently
someone yelled it out who'd seen and
because everyone knows Scarface suddenly
it worked better
shall we try it yeah let's try it this
is Sergei's Thanksgiving dinner
Thanksgiving dinner pasta sweet potatoes
you know I'd like to sweep a terrace ma
I look around at their orthotics
why are you our DOMA game I see the
jello with the walrus mom every time he
thought the jello goes down my throat
the wards get stuck on my it's a lot
like Liam Neeson if you give me sweet
potatoes and no harm rock under you
we're gonna take a break oh we're gonna
see already you killing we're gonna take
a break how much time
you